hello viewers welcome to Elm TV a
station where you watch you interact and
also you learn your teor today is
Mr an agriculture teacher in today's
lesson we are in form three lesson 10
and the topic is uh livestock production
form and the subtopic is uh livestock
rearing uh practices on to the lesson or
objectives uh by the end of this lesson
you should be able to explain uh State
uh various uh methods of controlling
parasite and disease other than
vaccination and the second one state any
three types of
vaccines uh the second uh the second
routine Management on RTO rearing that
is Parasite and Disease Control remember
we covered the first one is feeding uh
the first one feeding is a routine
Management in the previous lesson and
there are several methods that we
normally use to control uh parasite and
diseases a parasite is a an organism
which normally uh leave on another
organism at the expense of the other for
example a we have also parasite like the
ones which normally causes diseases and
therefore they are supposed to be
controlled so that you can end up having
high levels of production then the first
method of controlling parasite and
diseases is dew Waring and therefore
during Waring you can use appropriate uh
tool to to put the Dew all to introduce
into the dewers into the livestock you
can see there is a diagram here of a
person who is doing Dew Waring in ship
and the person is using a drenching gun
to introduce the antih helin tis those
are the drugs which are meant for redu
uh for controlling warms then we have
the second one is dipping and this is
aimed at controlling the Ecto or
external parasite where chemical such as
aide they are used then we have spraying
also acaricide is used but in spraying
you can use the hand spray method then
the fourth one we have pasture
management and during pasture management
you can use structures such as the pck
whereby you will be uh regulating the
the P or the G the greasing unit using
different bules and therefore whenever
the the animals are feeding on a
particular product the other products
should be closed to make sure that the
heat of the sun heats the eggs of the of
the parasite and therefore are
destroying them and therefore breaking
the cycle of parasite uh uh parasite
cycle then uh we go to the do that is
another one that is referred to The
Cutting of the tail or or tailing it is
also referred to as tailing and the
importance of this is to control the
bluefly infestation and the other one we
have the hoof triming whereby a hoof
cutter is normally used to cut the
overgrown Hooves so that you can control
the hoof rot diseases then we have dust
bath a dust bath is an example of a d b
here we have a pit Ash uh we have a pit
Ash
here which is normally provided to the
Potter so that they can bathe with it
and the pet Ash is is very very
important because it will kill the
parasite which normally affect Potter uh
then we have vaccination is another
method of controlling uh diseases or
controlling in the spreading of diseases
vaccination you can vaccinate your
animal you can
inject your animal with a particular
vaccine so that you can control the
disease from uh spreading then methods
of vaccination we have you can
administer the vaccine through injection
as you can see in this diagram the
animal is injected using a vaccine then
we have the second method we have Oro
vacine that's where you introduce the
vaccine through the mouth then we have
inhalation inhalation is through the
nose and also insertion at the caka when
it comes to poort Tre then uh types of
vaccines we have four uh in today's we
are going to cover four the first one
you have life varent vaccine is the one
which is administered when the disease
causing microorganism actually vaccine
is a disease causing microorganism who
ability to cause the disease has been
reduced and therefore for Life variant
vaccine is the one which is introduced
when the disease C microorganism or
pathogen is live then we have life
attenuated is the one which is normary
the disease CA microorganism is mixed
with some chemicals to reduce uh its uh
poers therefore it will not affect the
animal and the form the examples of
diseases which are controlled using this
meod or or this type of vaccine we have
Anthrax and also we have brucelosis we
have killed an all dead vaccine that is
where you kill the disease causing
microorganism then you mix it with
formal
forde there is a chemical uh then uh you
introduce into the body so that the body
of an animal can become stimulated to
produce its own antibodies then we have
the toxine vacine uh it is in form of
for marine and they actually once it is
introduced to the body of animal the
animal is stimulated to produce its own
immunity then we have properties of good
vaccine should be a good immunity it
should be as good as natural immunity
then the second one a long shelf life
the the immunity which should the
vaccine should have a a long uh keeping
shelf life that is the time the lifespan
uh before it EXP should be longer then
single dose should produce lifelong
immunity then the fourth one easy to
administer it is should not be
complicated when it comes to uh to
introduction of the vaccine into the
body then no side effect should not the
the animal or also should not harm the
farmer who is administering them to the
animal then compatible with other
vaccine yes a good vaccine should uh be
compatible with other types of vaccine
we have come to the end of today's
lesson and we are going I'm going to
give you assignment the first question
Define the following terms as using
lifestock production for uh the first
one is vacine and the second one is
vaccination then the second question is
highlight any four types of vaccine used
during uh life stock uh production then
we have refer uh reference you can refer
from secondary
agriculture book Student Book uh three
uh that the publisher is the Kenya
literature bu for more information you
can reach us at arim TV using the
following contacts the first one we have
SMS using that number then you can reach
us through YouTube uh Facebook at TV and
finally you can twit us at
tvk thank you for joining me in this
lesson till next lesson right